and I'm the marketing manager here at
Pine biotech so I'll quickly guide you
all through the registration process
process of this particular program named
chem informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
so this is the program page and the
program is going to commence from 27th
Jan and in between we'll be having one
more webinar which would be related to a
Hands-On session so we'll be uh telling
you about that particular webinar in a
short while we'll be sending you
invitation about it so when I'll scroll
down
um about the program overview the
curriculum Etc Dr Mohit has already uh
explained it in a very comprehensive and
extensive way so I'll directly jump on
to the registration process the
resources costing and the scholarship
part
so here you all can see there are three
different tenures uh in which one could
enroll for so there are some of the
resources common in all the three
tenures that are online tutorials that
you will be having access to the omics
logic learn portal which have more than
32 plus courses on different domains in
area of analysis then we have more than
16 plus example research projects again
on different uh ARF analysis and domain
plus case studies then you will have
access to the project examples the
coding sessions the session recordings
online Mentor Support Online technical
support certification of completion and
example Cloud pipelines on T bioinfo
server so these are the common resources
which one would have access to if
they'll enroll in any of the tenure now
what is the difference between the
three ten years in 45 days you will be
getting a full-fledged training you will
be trained related to drug Discovery
chem informatics you'll be taught
different software tool databases Etc
in 60 days tenure you have two different
opportunities so the first 45 days would
be devoted to your training part and the
next 15 days you will be devoted to how
you can draft a research proposal
presented to the mentor so that the
mentor can evaluate your research
proposal and guide you the changes or
any Amendment which would make your
research proposal more validated and
further you can work on your independent
research project also one second is the
you will have access to one-on-one
Mentor sessions so for example if we are
going through any training module and
you get stuck somewhere and you want to
meet mental one-on-one so we can fix an
exploratory call of your with the mentor
of around 15 to 20 minutes and you can
clarify each and every question
now the outcome for 60 days is a poster
presentation it could be in a omics
research Symposium or any other research
Symposium it could be in any
International Conference also now in 90
days you again have two different
opportunities first is one-on-one Mentor
sessions obviously and second is the
first 45 days would be devoted to your
training part and the next 45 days would
be devoted to you how you can develop
your independent research project
and that particular project would be
further publishable in a good
peer-reviewed Journal so the outcome
comes to be a research publication and
also a poster presentation so these this
uh this was the difference between the
three tenures so now you can see here on
my screen uh the pricing is in USD and
uh you can definitely change the pricing
according to your location so here
there is a drop down menu and in this
drop down menu there are different
currencies mentioned according to
different locations uh now if I click on
USD and I'll scroll down I can see the
pricing in USD for 45 days it's 150 for
60 days it's dollar 300 and for 90 days
it's dollar 450. and now uh till January
15 we are providing each and every
interested participant with a 50 person
scholarship and uh one of our
representative will uh
publish or will uh tell you the steps of
registering and will also tell you about
the coupon code which is chem 50
c-h-e-m chem is in capitals and Fike
zero I'll just tell you how you can
proceed further with the payment
checkout process also now for those who
are in India so the pricing is in INR
and when you'll scroll down you can see
that for 45 days the pricing is 7500
then for 60 days it's 10 000 and for 90
days it's fifteen thousand and likewise
you can change the currency depending
upon your location and see the pricing
or the fee for the program accordingly
now moving further uh telling you about
the payment procedure so for example if
I'm interested in 45 days tenure I'll
click on the buy now button
after clicking on buy now button I'll be
redirected to the omics logic checkout
page so I'll just quickly write type
here the coupon code that is scam 50.
click on apply and here you can see that
the coupon is applied successfully
message will pop out you will need to
fill out your user details like your
name your email your phone number your
country occupation organization Etc
click on this check box and select the
payment mode if you want to pay it via
stripe PayPal Etc now those who are
unable to pay via PayPal or stripe we
have alternative payment methods also
and for that you can
uh write us at marketing at the rate
omicslogic.com or you can ping us at the
official number that is plus nine one
nine eight seven six one three four one
two zero uh and we'll guide you with the
alternative payment methods also so this
was about the registration process the
scholarship and uh the fee so if anyone
is having any doubt related to the
registration process Etc uh please feel
free to unmute yourself and ask or
please feel free to write in the chat
box and I'll be there to assess and
guide you thank you